self-sufficiency moral behavior
education religious observation and
liberal democracy all of that went
together to say a person was respectable
and the middle class didn't really think
that the elite or the lower classes were
respectable so the this was their class
prejudice that we are respectable and
these others aren't
and then disreputable has to do with
what they thought was not respectable
and there was a lot of it and eventually
the middle class bought into that people
that came here because the the the
territory Mississippi's territory was
established in 200 years ago in 1816 and
in the state in 1819 they were all
infini inflicted with a disease called
Alabama fever and that disease was to
get rich quick and the local the
southerners were getting rich quick off
of raising cotton with slave labor and
the northerners there was a huge
northern population here we're getting
rich quick actually richer than the
cotton farmers as merchants so there was
an enormous amount of money made here in
fact in 1860 Montgomery County the
county was larger than it is today was
the seventh largest slave holding county
in the country and it was the largest
exporter of cotton for an inland
southern inland southern city we're in a
house built by German although he never
lived in it he was middle class person
he was involved in making gas lighting
for the city so the gas works but it
became the town house of a planning
family a georgian family that was rich
before the American Revolution was the
husband's part of the family that wife's
part of the family was the South
Carolina
family they own plantations about 15
miles east of here and they came into
town for several reasons one was life on
a plantation was incredibly lonely for
the owners of course maybe neighboring
plantations families would visit but it
was generally a lonely existence and so
what they did was they came into town
for the social activities that are
available the leisure activities of
course that are available in town the
husband also had political aspirations
and so they they came into this town in
the 1850s they were rich and as you'll
see in shots of the house it's not a
grand house it was really a middle-class
house that was lived in by the landed
elite for five or six years in the 1850s
and we're sitting now in the back parlor
you can see behind me the front parlor
so what would go on in this house say
and the ladies sphere the lady of the
house is here pretty much all of the
time most outside activities weren't
acceptable for a respectable
middle-class lady so in the entrance
hall there is a tray that calling cards
would be left so women often call on one
another and talk they're doing what
people have done since the beginning of
time talking but they're doing so in a
setting that's rather elegant and
polished and sophisticated so there's a
table behind me a center table that has
a tea set on it ladies would come and
talk there's a square grand piano in the
room there's a violin in the room but
ladies could not play violins ladies
couldn't raise their arms that high they
were cinched in ladies played keyboard
instruments they played guitars behind
me in the front parlor the formal parlor
for visitors there is also a
checkerboard
so in the family in the evening that
would sit in this room which is a more
masculine room but more comfortable
older furniture that can easily be open
to the front parlor as you can see
through these sliding doors but they
would read there's a secretary bookcase
over there there books around there
sewing for the woman women often sewed
not for just for practical reasons but
for recreational reasons doing an
embroidery in petit point and Grosse
Pointe and tatting in those sorts of
things as well there it representations
in this room of how they use their
leisure time for example here there is a
print of middle-class family gathering
with children around a piano here is a
collection of shells which sir is it
makes several statements one is we can
afford to go to the seashore so it's a
you know show off in a way but it also
says we're interested in Natural History
this was the science that was of
interest to most educated people the
outdoor activities the activities that
are primarily associated with men and
associated with all classes would would
be gambling on anything you can imagine
on fist fights on knife fights on horse
racing on pool they played pool they
tried to make it illegal but primarily
on cards in fact the gamblers pretty
much control the city until 1830s when
the state legislature made the condition
of Montgomery getting a city charter
rather than a town charter to get rid of
the gamblers and they were driven out
they went to Texas and they were
massacred by Santa Ana at Goliad that
was before the Alamo so gambling by the
rich by the elite had been accepted the
elite thought it's fine for us to gamble
but not for ordinary people to gamble
and so when these professional gamblers
took over the elite turned against it
you would think that church would be an
outdoor outside activity and in fact
many people in antebellum America went
to church but only one in five members
or 20% of the American public were
actually members of churches it was very
difficult to be a member of church the
strictures that controls the thou shalt
nots was extremely extensive and it was
monitored and people were thrown out of
church because they had brought
discredit upon that particular church or
denomination or again about Christianity
itself so the membership was very low
just and the teens or 20s and and people
were routinely thrown out but they went
hear the sermons the sermons were sort
of a form of entertainment and so as
when the north got rid of slavery or was
getting rid of slavery they started
becoming hyper critical about southern
slavery and so southerners stopped going
to the north and stopped intermarrying
with northern families and so forth so
they started going to the southern
mountains and two springs there were a
dozen or so mineral springs in Alabama
and they would go and it would be a
place that they could hunt and fish and
take the mineral waters and dance and
gamble and drink and and so forth and
matchmaking it was very important as
class began to solidify right before the
civil war that elite families what we
would call upper-class families started
intermarrying and so that was a place
they could do that so when the cotton
crop is coming in in the fall money is
appearing they're having money you know
they had money when the cotton was sold
they came back into town and so at that
time that's when religious denominations
had their denominational meeting
political parties had their meetings the
legislature went into session and that's
when circuses operas theaters all
started coming that's when the State
Fair occurred and then there were all
kind of private parties as well they
sort of adopted the Mardi Gras type of
activity so Mardi Gras in the United
States began in Mobile and and and then
spread to New Orleans but it came up
here but it wasn't associated with the
Carnival season and right before Ash
Wednesday and in the beginning of Lent
it was associated with New Year's so
there was this extended period that was
all sort of activities planners that
lived on their plantations may come into
town and take rentals for this season so
that was when the town was full and very
active so it went from Thanksgiving
which was a national holiday for a very
long time it included Christmas
Christmas our Alabama was the first
state to make Christmas as a holiday
whereas in New England Christmas was
outlawed it was pagan or associated with
Catholicism or certainly frivolous so
Christmas became was very important and
in New Year's and then they throw in
Andrew Jackson who is very important for
this area because he increased the size
of the state terrifically when he
succeeded in the Creek Indian War and
that land was taken and the Indians were
shipped off to what is now Arkansas in
Oklahoma there was a whole nother set of
activities and this ties in more with a
respectability thing the northerners are
really running the schools here they're
not just merchants but there was no
public school system there were private
schools run by northern school masters
and that they formed societies like the
Franklin Society was the Society for
printers it
assisted all over the country there was
the Lyceum that was supposed to educate
people on practical things there there
was a society for young mechanics the
mechanics association mechanic then
meant a craftsman so they were talking
about science and machinery and and how
to improve themselves if all of these
had to do with self-improvement and
that's what they existed for but in
reality they quickly became a form of
entertainment so there would be lectures
on polar regions on the holy land on
Mount Vernon of course this was the
period that Mount Vernon George
Washington's home right outside of
Washington was about to be demolished so
there was a national outcry this is a
period of great nationalism and one of
the leaders of that movement is William
louse Yancy who lived here who Abraham
Lincoln reputedly said single-handedly
started the civil war some southerners
would think perhaps who is Harriet
Beecher snow snow and Uncle Tom's Cabin
but he was one of the leaders in raising
money and buying Mount Vernon for the
public and preserving it so hypnotist
dog shows magic shows all of these sorts
of things you know came out of these
so-called literary and scientific and
professional societies so I find that
and and I mentioned in my talk that
Queen Victoria is seeing the same circus
that plays in Antebellum Montgomery
Alabama New Yorkers and people in
Philadelphia and I didn't mention it but
in st. Louis and New Orleans and so
forth her are seeing the same actors
hearing the same opera sung by the same
opera stars that are here they're all
seeing Barnum Barnum came here they're
all seeing the Siamese twins
they came here they're they're doing the
same things they're hearing some of the
same
lectures so there are a lot of
commonality in people not just the
commonality of human relations of course
human relations are the same all over
but in their chosen activities they're
the same this weekend we're in
Montgomery Alabama with the help of our
local cable partner Charter
Communications next we visit the last
home of the Great Gatsby author F scott
Fitzgerald
well currently we're in the last of four
houses that Scott and Zelda lived in
this is in Montgomery Alabama in a
neighborhood called old Cloverdale which
is registered on the National Historic
Register of places when you come to the
Fitzgerald Museum the first thing you're
gonna find is a house that's been saved
from demolition which is it's supremely
important this couple averaged about
five months to stop for 14 years now
this house that we inhabit has been
significantly expanded after that what's
Cotton's other lived here it was broken
into apartments but we still use the
downstairs as the museum and you're
gonna find the artifacts that date back
to the mid 19th century
Zelda's grandparents family Bibles baby
shoes an odd assortment of books that
come from the 19th century but to show
you that her family was very affluent as
you continue on through our museum we're
gonna take you all the way through the
1970s when Scotty their daughter
Scott until his only child moved back to
Montgomery and she lived here for the
last 16 years of her life and everything
in between
obviously the things that are most
important to us and that we really
treasure the most are our direct
artifacts from Scott and Zelda we show
you a house that was the turning point
for Scott and Zelda when they got here
when they moved here we have photos of
Zelda right after she moved here sitting
on top of her trunks almost like a
princess the top of atop her herb the
spoils of war and this trunk say 919
felder Avenue owned him which is where
we are when they moved here the idea was
to regroup Zelda had just gotten out of
the hospital when I say the hospital I
mean the most prominent hospital in the
world prongs John clinic in Switzerland
and approached our clinic Zelda had been
diagnosed as schizophrenic when they get
here she's been told she's cured of
schizophrenia which is not possible and
probably not her mental illness so what
this house was was a landing pad
it was a regrouping as I've said stage
and it wasn't the sort of place where
you're gonna find Scott and Zelda
engaging in
domestic activities if you will it was
the sort of place where they were gonna
be planning their next moves so
Montgomery enters the story of f scott
Fitzgerald in 1918 shortly after he
dropped out of Princeton because his
grades were so bad that the
administration wasn't gonna let him stay
on for a fifth or six year this was
during World War one when he came to
Montgomery Fitzgerald was probably
remembering some of these stories his
father had told him about how he would
help Confederate spies sneak behind
Union lines in Maryland back during the
Civil War southern girls obviously
something that Fitzgerald is very
interested in since he considered
himself even though he was from st. Paul
a southerner when he gets here he's 21
years old he has a rejected novel in his
knapsack he is a second lieutenant
bottom of the totem pole and the place
where he was staying was called Camp
Sheridan it's no longer around but it
was about two miles north of the Capitol
in downtown Montgomery and that was a
camp that about 20,000 men came through
between 1917 and 1918 now obviously as
most historians know the war ends in
November of 1918
so Fitzgerald gets here about six months
before his opportunity to become a hero
in battle ends but during that time
period II meets a young woman and he
meets her there's two stories we at the
Fitzgerald museum believe that he
originally met Zelda at winter place
which is a marvelous old mansion in
downtown Montgomery a lot of fancy
parties used to happen there but only
officers were invited to these parties
if you were our grunt in the army you
weren't going to be getting in the
invitation to a ball such as this and
there apparently was an exchange between
Scott and Zelda a bit of a flirtation
and it ended with them saying let's meet
at the Montgomery Country Club next
weekend for the dance that's going to be
held there and that's where the legend
er really comes forth Scott and Zelda at
a country club dance Montgomery Alabama
really falling in love following the
publication of Scott's second novel the
beautiful on the dams the couple needed
new horizons new vistas so they moved to
Europe during this time period
Zelda's personality created a firestorm
of interest in her
cuz after Scott second novel she wrote a
review of that novel in which she said
that he had been pulling limes from her
letters and her Diaries and using them
as dialogue for his main characters this
ended up with Zelda being declared queen
of the flappers by Hearst international
magazine in 1923 that same summer they
show up in France spend a lot of time on
the French Riviera especially in places
like Cap d'Antibes and during this time
period Zelda finds out that being the
world's first flapper does not
ingratiate you with people like Gertrude
Stein Ford Madox Ford Cole Porter Ernest
Hemingway Edith Wharton and a plethora
of other very serious artists that are
working in France or visiting France
often during this time period so she
begins painting early pastoral are her
initial foray these are by the way being
done as Scott is finishing the edits as
a 28-year old boy for The Great Gatsby
Fitzgerald believes that the best option
the best vehicle for bringing Zelda's
paintings to the public is to have a
joint press run with the publication of
his new novel The Great Gatsby and
Zelda's first paintings being sold on
exhibition in New York City the problem
is is that Scott's novel is not well
received by the critics it only sells
2,000 copies and Zelda's paintings are
also rejected as being the work of his
amateur Playgirl sort of painter the
tension in the marriage though is a
result of Zelda's quitting painting
professionally but continuing to do many
to dedicate many hours to art work at
home for example in the museum and these
are from the Beinecke collection at Yale
University we have the earliest known
paper dolls that Zelda ever produced
these were multi-media paper dolls and
they were done as gifts for children or
just for their own daughter Scotty to
play with however the new it girl of
America
by 1926 and 27 the years following
Gatsby was no longer the flapper it was
the actress and when they get to
Hollywood Scott tells Zelda more or less
you need to be more like women like
Louis Moran who was a seventeen year old
girl when they met and already had a
career in which she dedicated her
artistic mind to making money with her
artistic production Zelda does not find
this very flattering she has a huge
fight with Fitzgerald in which she burns
all of the artwork that she had been
producing in Hollywood and the couple
very much tail between legs had to leave
Hollywood very very soon after they
arrived and moved to a country house
where hopefully they would be better at
damage control in terms of their public
reputations as we continue we find out
that Zelda soon dedicates herself to
ballet under the tutelage of a woman who
had been a prima ballerina in Paris in
the early 1920s and was now acting as an
instructor at the Russo Parisian ballet
school
Madame lubob egorova the relationship
between Madame Liubov egorova and her
apprentice student Zelda would be the
equivalent of a modern celebrity such as
Miley Cyrus retiring from her career and
taking up the life of a professional
athlete today modern scholars see this
as the first major showing of Zelda's
bipolar nature for the next two years
Zelda practiced ballet as if she was
meant to be a prima ballerina however
she was 28 years old when she began this
endeavor and it ends two years later
with a mental breakdown in Paris in
which she tries to take her own life for
the next 14 months she's at Pranjal
clinic in Switzerland and after her time
there she moved here to Montgomery to
this house that we stayed in
at present they diagnosed a Zelda
schizophrenic they also pronounced her
cured of schizophrenia and when she
moves to this house the first thing she
wants to do is write a novel about what
happened with a girl in her late 20s who
decided to become a ballerina that's
what she's working on here in this house
she works on it very hard while for
about six weeks
writes the majority of the novel and
when Fitzgerald comes back from his
second trip to Hollywood he reads the
novel and it becomes the major spat of
their marriage
Fitzgerald feeling that he is the one
who was the novelist and he's the one
who should get all the accolades for
writing and Zelda feeling that since she
had failed as a painter and failed as a
ballerina this was the last resort for
her creativity we're now in what was the
great room or the receiving room of the
house when Scott ins got a lift here
their time here was very tumultuous not
only because of Zelda's wanting to write
a novel and Scott having mixed feelings
about that but also because Elda's
father died while she was living in this
house and Fitzgerald was given his
second contract job in Hollywood one
which he initially turned down at $750 a
week but then could not refuse a raise
to $1,200 a week by MGM studios during
that time period Zelda finishes her
novel and then she has a second
breakdown when Scott gets back to
Montgomery leading them to have to leave
Montgomery and go to Sheppard Pratt
Hospital which was a an annex of Johns
Hopkins Hospital in Baltimore Maryland
that summer Zelda finished her novel and
this photograph was taken of the famous
couple shortly after the novel was
released this was a two-shot of Scott
and Zelda a picture that would have been
posed for and the expressions on their
faces are unmistakable there is a
unhappiness in the marriage that is
becoming very difficult to overcome
Fitzgerald looking nervous and Zelda
looking very unhappy that she is the
subject of attention and the reason is
these photographs are appearing beside
reviews of her novel which are basically
calling her third-rate writer and a
woman whose only being published because
her husband is that Scott Pitts
after the publication of Zelda's novel
her mental health continued to
deteriorate for the rest of the 30s she
spent over 90% of her waking hours in
mental institutions leaving the great
writer F scott Fitzgerald alone with
this only child a daughter by the way
who was coming of age in 1933 Scott sent
Scotty to boarding schools Scotty was
going to be in boarding schools or in
college until the day Fitzgerald died in
1940 but Fitzgerald was not a man to
leave no vestige of family life behind
so he continued to work earnestly on a
stent collection that he had begun with
her in 1928 when they were living in
Paris in 1973
Scotty wrote the preface for the
collection of the last uncollected short
stories that her father and mother had
written in the preface she lists this
tenth collection as one of only five
artifacts left in her possession that
had belonged to her family that is
indicative of the transience of this
story Scott and Zelda never making a
place that Scotty could really call home
these stamps by the way are taken from
postcards and letters that the
Fitzgerald's had sent to their friends
during the heady days of the 1920s when
money was easy short stories paid
Fitzgerald a lot of money and were easy
to sell and the family was able to
travel at will the 1930s were a much
different ballgame for Scott and Zelda
but there was one thing that remained
true and that was Scott's dedication to
maintaining a family life for Scotty at
a time period when her mother was
nowhere to be found when her mother was
living 100 percent of her time in mental
institutions and Fitzgerald was
struggling to find work as the 30th war
on fitzgerald began to despair that
Zelda would ever be cured of her mental
illness and indeed she was never cured
of her mental illness however his income
was dropping in her hospital bills were
rising and also Scotty's boarding school
bills were breaking him by 1936 he was
$40,000 in
and had nothing to show for it so when
Hollywood came calling in 1937 for the
third time and offered Fitzgerald a one
thousand dollar a week contract
Fitzgerald had no choice but to leave
Zelda behind in Asheville North Carolina
at Highland Hospital and travel across
the country to begin life anew as a 41
year old man he spent the next three and
a half years working in Hollywood during
that time he had one film credit for a
film called the three comrades he had a
girlfriend named Sheila Graham she was
every bit of his second wife but he
would never divorce Zelda so he and
Sheila's relationship remained
clandestine with only Hollywood insiders
and friends of them knowing about it the
night before he died they went to go see
this movie it was the only film of 1940
at the Catholic decency league put on
their blacklist it was an
extraordinarily raucous and funny film
and by all accounts Fitzgerald had you
enjoyed it immensely however when he
stood up to leave the theater to get out
of his seat he experienced a fainting
spell that is believed to have been a
heart attack it would have been his
fourth heart attack of the year Sheila
his girlfriend wanted to call an
ambulance and hack Fitzgerald taken home
however because it was the premiere of
the movie and the the theater that night
was filled with a listers and the the
highest paid actors Fitzgerald did not
want to be seen being carried out of the
theater on a gurney so he had Sheila
Graham wait until the theater was empty
and then help him to the car so that he
could go home the next morning he woke
up they had brunch together and he died
of a heart attack he was 44 in the end
Montgomery is the beginning and end of
the Fitzgerald story that's where they
met in 1918 it's where they tried to
live when they found out they were
pregnant with their first child
it's where they came when the wheels
fell off the relationship off the
relationship and off of Zelda's mental
state in 1931 but more and more what
really seems to be the part of the story
that visitors find the most point
is that their daughter a girl who grew
up without a home who grew up on the
road for the first 14 years of her life
when she needed a place to call home
later on in her life Montgomery was
where she landed if you come to the
Fitzgerald Museum you're gonna find out
the deaf scott Fitzgerald is more than
just a writer he's not the genius that
can come up with everything on his own
he needed a partner he needed someone to
give him a life full enough of ideas
that he could write the great American
novels that woman was Zelda ser a
Montgomery and by birth and aristocratic
by train training and a woman that
Fitzgerald felt exemplified the spirit
of an age in which they lived and
allowed him to chronicle to be the great
voice of an entirely new youth
generation following in the footsteps of
World War one during book TV's recent
visit to Montgomery Alabama
we spoke with Nimrod Frazier who
recounts the history of the 167th
Infantry Regiment during World War one
in his book send the Alabamians
[Music]
[Music]
the 167th US Infantry was made up of
Alabama soldiers the Alabama National
Guard was created in 1912 and a guy
named bill screws was sent here as a
regular army captain to train that
regiment and to build it up so he
between 1912 and 1916 he built it up to
5,000 men he took them to the Mexican
border and and for advanced infantry
training these were mostly poor guys
seeking adventure most of these people
had never been outside of the state of
Alabama they knew they could go to the
Mexican border when that was announced
and it represented an opportunity for
travel paid well for the times given a
uniform it was a pretty much a lark in
the beginning and it became a very very
serious combat situation once they got
to Europe President Woodrow Wilson and
his newly appointed Secretary of War
Newton D Baker received rather reluctant
permission from the current Mexican
government to pursue the bandit leader
President Wilson was an anti-war
candidate in 1916 but he had supported
the creation of the National Guard he
saw the war in Europe and was very
afraid of our involvement in it so there
were basically were several reasons for
his committing us to the Mexican border
one is at three guerrilla groups one of
most famous being led by microphone by
the name of Pancho Villa were trying to
overthrow the democratic government of
Mexico Villa had across the Rio Grande
River into New Mexico and and killed a
bunch of Americans and when he did that
it was the trigger point for Wilson's
making the decision to send all of the
regularly and all of the National Guard
to the Mexican border for training the
wreck Lima portion of it was
led by General Pershing of one-star
general at that time and they pursued
Villa into the heartland of Mexico but
without success they never captured him
but the Alabama regiment actually they
were for Alabama regiments down there
totaling five thousand men that they
trained in advanced infantry warfare and
became back to to Alabama in 1917 and we
went into the war in 1917 and and he
they will immediately brought to New
York to New York to Long Island and made
it part of the rainbow division when
that Alabama regiment was created
secretary Ward Baker sent an order down
here two screws down here to Montgomery
and said you took five thousand men to
Mexican border you choose the best 3720
out of them put them in a National Guard
regiment bring them here to Long Island
and we will have them assimilated into
the rainbow division in August 1917 from
all over the country
the division was composed of crack
National Guard units from 26 states and
the District of Columbia
[Applause]
but many states of the union the many
colors and shades of thought and points
of view brought together here all
inspire the name rainbow division all of
the ancillary units the support units
came from all over the United States
they when the division was announced
MacArthur was there and and they said
well what should you call this division
and and he said and one of the reporters
said it stretches like a rainbow across
the United States he said we'll call it
the rainbow division because it goes
from one side of the country to the
other and that's what President Wilson
and secretary wall beta Baker wanted
they wanted a representative division so
that the the water partment then
cherry-picked these four divisions from
the National Guard the best four and
then screws cherry-picked the five
thousand soldiers for the best 3,700
when they got to Europe they were very
welcomed and you must realize that the
British had sent a delegation to
Washington to see President Wilson and
said we want we want 75 battalions to
put in a in the trenches under our
experienced leaders the French sent a
delegation to Washington they said we
want a fully trained division to go into
into our army President Wilson who had
appointed General Pershing is the head
of the European war President Wilson and
pushing agreed that they wanted
Americans there but only to serve as
Americans under Americans so in the
division when these Ford winter
divisions got to Europe all of them
needed more training they were
considered by the army to be not ready
to fight
so they went immediately into entered to
training a training January February in
March
and then in March they were rotated in
the rainbow division was rotated into
these trenches at a place called
baccarat it was a quiet theoretically a
quiet zone the Germans were using it to
bring soldiers out of that combat to let
them rest and the French were there
opposing him so our our Alabama soldiers
our 42nd division soldiers were twinned
with the French and then after they had
been integrated to some extent after a
week or so they were operated a alone
and under French offices senior officers
and and then they stayed there for 110
days in baccarat down over in eastern
France in Russia
they'd been a dramatic change the the
Communists took over from the Czar and
in the Communists had no stomach for the
war the Czar had been an ally of the
Allies and that was no longer the case
so this freed up 62 regiments of Germans
who then were sent to the champagne to
eat the Western Front 55 miles from
Paris and the Germans teed up a big big
offensive to take Paris and the Alabama
regiment was put in between the rainbow
division and the Alabama regiment will
put in between two French divisions on
one of the key accesses to Paris and
fought extremely well and saved Paris if
we'd lost that battle then the fate of
Paris had fallen the fate of France in
Europe would have been sealed the whole
attitude of the French changed for
supreme commander Fache was a French guy
that commanded all of the Allied troops
in Europe fuch then declared a
counter-attack
and the Remo division was sent down to
chateau-thierry
rested for three or four days and then
the Fort Lee 167 s was
by truck on the night of the 24th 25th
of July 1918 to a place called Eppie aid
and then they went by foot for six miles
up to the crawlers farm and on the 26th
of July participated in an epic battle
certainly de epic Falabella it was the
biggest bloodletting of Alabama soldiers
that had taken place since Gettysburg it
was a tremendous loss of life then and
this on the 26th of July there were
there were 163 Alabama soldiers killed
in a four and a half hour fight it was a
brutal fight but screws was successful
they killed 283 Germans 48 hours were
supporting the Alabama regiment on the
right they were killed off so the bloody
bloody day and that we had about a
thousand wounded from Alabama my father
was shot up in that battle to the battle
that they are gone forests at the hill
called the cote de chelly on it was a
reinforced strong point it had concrete
bunkers and very experienced Germans
there it was a it was extremely
important place where the railroads and
supply lines crossed through and in the
faller that meant that we would cut the
vital supply lines that were connecting
the north and south German armies and we
were successful there and and and in the
war was tremendously shortened there was
a great piece of machine gun work that
was done by the 150 first Georgia
machine gun battalion whether they used
indirect fire no firing from Hill 263
over the heads of the attacking soldiers
on to hit the cote de xiao lian and
using a used a million rounds of machine
gun ammunition in five thirty minutes of
uninterrupted fire then stopped for 15
minutes to allow the salt and then raise
their target and fired for 15 minutes
more on the reverse slope of that hill
it was a extremely creative piece of
machine gun work it was supported by
these these assaulting infantryman it
was a legendary success that was shared
by the nation but it was very very
important in Alabama I mean it really
meant that these country boys all of
whom were grandsons of Confederates had
participated in saving freedom and
democracy for and had distinguished
themselves in Europe alongside of the
Regular Army troops they came home as
heroes this the Capitol grounds this
building is located on the Capitol
grounds just across the street from here
there was the biggest assembly of people
in Alabama that we've ever had on the
grounds of the Capitol there was 75,000
people who welcomed that one regiment
home to Alabama when they marched up
next Avenue it was a hugely big
outpouring around there were parades in
the Huntsville and Gadsden in Anniston
in Montgomery and in Mobile
a huge outpouring of gratitude but then
it was all over it's like we are that
way as Americans we we don't like to we
might celebrate wall while it's going on
but then we want to get it over with the
legacy is that it brought out the best
in us we were there as a really good
combat soldiers and we served the nation
and we came out of the Confederacy into
the modern world that was the legacy of
this regiment it gave us a lot of pride
that people on the street here knew that
we were equal to the New York regiment
and as a combat unit
it fulfilled today Alabama has one of
the largest National Guard units in the
United States soldier soldiering is an
honored profession in this state it's
not looked down upon volunteering for
service is is a big part of who we are
for more information on book TV's recent
visit to Montgomery and the many other
destinations on our city's tour go to
c-span org slash cities tour you're
watching book TV on c-span - television
for serious readers here's a look at
what's on prime-time tonight we'll kick
off the evening at 6:45 p.m. Eastern
with Tom Wainwright reporting on the 300
billion dollar illegal drug business
then at 8:15 Douglas rushkoff explores a
new US economy at 9:15 NBC News Richard
Engel shares his experiences reporting
from the Middle East and on afterwards
at 10:00 former Bush administration
official John you looks at the growth of
presidential power during the Obama
administration and we'll finish up our
primetime programming at 11:00 with
former first lady Laura Bush who talks
about the progress of women in
Afghanistan since 2001 that all happens
tonight on c-span two's book TV
Christel right your new book con job
who's being conned and who's doing the
conning well I think Democrats are doing
the conning particularly of black
Americans and women I argue in my book
con job because they're kind of like the
Democrat Party in my view over the last
half century is kind of like a used car
salesman it pedals all these promises
and pledges to black Americans we're
gonna make things better since LBJ since
1964 we're gonna make you smarter richer
more educated fast forward to today
black Americans are none of those things
in fact I talked about in con job how
the head of the Congressional Black
Caucus last year said that blacks were
in quote a state of emergency under the
first black president mind year so it's
I look at the Democrat Party kind of
like a used car salesman in that they
say hey they're really slickly dressed
and they want to sell you a great
product they say don't look under the
hood because you might you might not
actually get what you're voting for and
with women you know it's always the war
on women right there the abortion Lobby
is very strong in the Democrat Party and
they painted under this veil of
pro-choice but when I dig some digging
on Planned Parenthood's website and then
their financial reports what I found is
by the age a woman turns 45 in America
three out of every ten women who turns
45 in America will have had an abortion
and I don't know if that and they boast
about it on their website is something
we should champion and as a woman I find
that it's nothing I you know women that
I know who have made the tough decision
to have an abortion I don't agree with
abortion that's not something that's
that we should be proud of but that's a
statistic that they boast about and I
mean I could go on and on but those are
just some of the highlights of the book
when it comes to illegal immigration you
know oftentimes what I found in doing
research for this book if you go on the
Democrat on the DNC's website they have
about fit a list of 50 different
constituents and you know my mother used
to always tell me a person who tries to
be master of many things or to many
people usually a master of none of those
things so a lot of times they'll
advocate the Democrat Party for one
constituent that cannibalise is another
and there's no better example
and I highlight this in con job than
illegal immigration illegal immigration
is enemy number one in black Americans
what happens when immigration increases
by about 10 percent illegal immigration
jobs declined for blacks to the tune of
almost 6 percent and wages by about 2.5
percent you have Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders particularly Hillary
Clinton saying she's going to go further
than Barack Obama did and use executive
order if she has to to allow the 11
million people to stay here permanently
that harms black Americans so my book
really I wrote this book and the timing
is perfect 2016 my book came out a
little over a month ago to wake
everybody up to say look you don't have
to be a conservative like me but know
what you're voting for has a Democrat
Party really delivered on promises to
blacks to women and really liberals you
know in general is what the book is
about so that's probably more than you
wanted to hear Peter but no 96% of
African Americans voted for Barack Obama
over time 90% African Americans vote for
the Democratic candidate yep and I think
that is a tragedy because the lock stock
and barrel vote that blacks have given
Democrats over the last half-century has
not gotten us I don't think that the
parity with white Americans that Martin
Luther King wanted for us to have and I
think in many ways it has kept us I hate
to use you know analogies about slavery
and all this but I feel like it has kept
us impoverished as a race and when you
look at little in 1964 Daniel Patrick
Moynihan I talked about this in the book
he said that he was disturbed by the
fact that 23 percent of black babies
were born out of wedlock and he warned
President Johnson in his Moynihan report
which is called the the Negro family a
case for national action
he told President Johnson if we don't do
something about this you're gonna see
generational poverty and crime
developing within the black race because
at the same time that Moynihan found the
broken family emerging among black
Americans he also saw an increased
dependent
of black women in single-family homes
you know and they were the head of the
homes dependency on welfare fast forward
to today seventy-two percent of black
babies are born out of wedlock and you
know you can go to Brookings Institute
or heritage and all the data is the same
on the left and the right a child who is
born into a single-parent household has
about a seventy percent chance of
growing up in poverty and not getting an
education so I really want black
Americans to think this is an important
election who is really talking to you
about what policies they're actually
going to implement to get you jobs not
making promises like Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders on records you know both
of them have been in office a long time
they're promising all these things you
know we're going to stop mass
incarceration of blacks we're gonna
bring black jobs we're going to you know
reform the prison system all these
things but they haven't done any of that
stuff over the last you know thirty
years that Hillary's been running for
president really she's out of every job
Under the Sun they're pandering what I
say is that they're saying that black
black lives matter but for them it's
really all about black votes because
what have either of them done in their
records to help improve the state of
black America that's what I and I think
you have Donald Trump on the other side
while he is making some statements that
I think he needs to clarify about white
supremacist the Klan and David Duke at
the same time he is actually uttering
the words black Americans he talks about
how he's going to ease black
unemployment in his immigration plan by
getting rid of j-1 visas which allow
foreign young workers to come over here
and you know what he wants to replace it
with all on his website he has a great
policy plan I wish he talked about it
more he wants to replace it with the
inner-city jobs Bank where businesses
corporations you name it actually have
to are going to be forced to go to a
jobs Bank where young black people who
are unemployed put their resumes I think
this is innovative it's more jack kemp
style right Enterprise Zones
and I want to hear Donald Trump more
talk about that and really repudiate
white supremacists though
which he kind of did today on The Today
Show he actually said for the first time
he does not want their vote so I was
glad to hear that because you can't talk
out of both sides of your mouth crystal
right we hear from people on our morning
show on our call-in programs on c-span
and book TV black conservative I just
don't get it yeah they don't get it they
don't trust me they think I'm I get
called Uncle Tom [ __ ] like you know
you're working for the man well I don't
get paid for any virtually none of my
activism is paid I mean I got paid to
write this book but it's a modest you
know sum of money and I think the reason
why though is because we do see I would
say my party use a lot of black
conservatives to their advantage and
they used them as puppets I think at a
certain point there were times when ben
Carson when he was appearing on a
certain conservative Network before he
ran for president was saying things that
weren't authentic to dr. Carson I heard
when he spoke at the president's Prayer
Breakfast so what happens a lot of times
is I think black Americans have a right
to distrust some black conservatives
because the ones that you see sometimes
propped up through conservative media
outlets somehow lose their identity and
they are not they're no longer authentic
in their voice I would say to black
Americans however there are many
conservatives like me who I tell it like
it is I'm able to be introspective about
my own party when my party says stupid
let things like Donald Trump has said
stupid things like Haley Barbour who
said he didn't remember this the civil
rights movement being all that bad and
segregated when he grew up in the
segregated south of Mississippi so I
tell it like it is but I also look I
don't paint all liberals alike I don't
paint I mean I know it sounds like
because my book con job is a critique on
the Democrat Party but I think for black
Americans what I would say is we do a
little homework there's a rich history
with the party of Lincoln and I
emphasize the party of Lincoln because
that's that was a good party then with
black Americans Lincoln and his
Republican Party was created because
they fundamentally wanted to break away
from the Whig
who want to expand slave states out west
Lincoln wanted parody like Martin Luther
King for black Americans the Republican
Party for up for the 13th 14th 15th
amendment so there's a history there
there's a reason why black Americans
like me believe fundamentally that the
policies conservatives offer empowering
any more than Democrat so I would just
you know I I think some of that is going
away because you do see after President
Barack Obama's nearly two terms black
Americans are really frustrated Tavis
Smiley and others are saying gosh I
don't really know if he's delivered on
the promise that he made and does he
really deserve did we deserve to give
him over 90 percent of our vote so this
is a good thing I just think everybody
should have their eyes wide open I'm a
Republican but that doesn't mean just
because you have an R next to your name
you're always gonna earn my vote I'm
just saying that black America in order
to have any political power in this
country we have got to diversify our
political thought process we've got to
do it no other race and I'm going to
repeat this no other race gives their
nearly their entire vote to one party
put black Americans and then we complain
when Democrats don't deliver on promises
so I I just think that's got to stop
that's the only way you're gonna have
real political power and you're gonna
lift yourselves out of poverty you got
to stop asking what a party can do for
you what you can do for yourself then
the party can kind of help you along I
think
is a republican party comfortable with
you know I don't I think the Republican
Party has a great uneasiness with me
because they can't put me into a box I'm
not I'm not I'm not going to use names
about my peers that I like but I'm not
necessarily predictable and I frankly
don't think that any party should have
patsies that are its supporters we and
that's what we're dealing with right now
fundamentally the party wants to be
controlled by the GOP establishment
which is frankly a bunch it's an
exclusive club I find I've taken great
offense to them trying to rig an
election that Donald Trump is winning I
mean on election a nomination process at
Donald Trump is running fairly and
squarely and what this really is about
is the establishment in Washington very
concerned and disturbed they have lost
political power influence and money and
it's made up largely of white males and
the very people like Mitt Romney today
who gave a speech and I couldn't hear it
all he gave a speech condemning Donald
Trump who by the way in 2012 he praised
for supporting his campaign I find it
really repugnant because Romney ran one
of the most whitest campaigns that I can
remember I wanted to help his campaign
volunteer I was shut out at every turn I
was a Gingrich delegate I went on
national television when my guy was not
winning anything beyond South Carolina
and I got behind our nominee Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney did nothing to grow the
party the party stayed very white under
Mitt Romney and what happened Mitt
Romney lost the black Asian Hispanic and
woman vote Mitt Romney is a failure the
establishment has been a failure to grow
this party Donald Trump is doing these
things and that's why they're mad they
their power deserves my party deserves
to be burned down and built anew in con
job two people who appear in your book
Allen West and Cornel West what's the
difference between Cornel West and Allen
West well Allen West actually endorsed
my book Allen West is a Republican he
was elected as a member of Congress in
Florida he's a great friend of mine
I've learned a lot from Allen West did
you know just was very friendly with him
when he was a congressman and Cornel
West is a professor at Princeton I think
Cornel West has come out to support
Bernie Sanders Cornel West I mentioned I
think throughout the book because Cornel
West in my opinion is is part of the
race hustle movement and and I put him
in I love him in the category with Al
Sharpton because Cornel West has always
trotted out by the mainstream media when
we need quote black spokespeople and I'm
you know when I was growing up my
parents never gave me a memo that I had
to have black people speak on my behalf
because my parents grew up during the
segregated south and they they were
called the n-word my parents had to sit
in the back of the bus in Richmond
Virginia so they always taught me to
speak for myself as a black woman so I
take great offense between you know when
when the media wants to reduce black
people to voices in a collective box
that have to be relegated to
spokespeople Peter you don't have a
white spokesperson that speaks on your
behalf to you maybe maybe you do and I
don't know about it but I think I missed
that memo so when you look at Cornel
West he's making a lot of money writing
books about what black people should
think and do and now he's the voice of
black people he teaches this stuff at
Princeton Allen West on the other hand
is telling people speak for yourself he
was a loud mouth in a good way
congressman he tells it like it is
and he is much more of a hero and a
champion in me for the cause of black
American than Cornel West will ever be
so they're a little bit from crystal
right her new book con job how Democrats
gave us crime sanctuary cities abortion
profiteering and racial division
you're watching book TV on c-span too
every day books are reviewed by
publications throughout the country
here's a look at some recently reviewed
books chief foreign correspondent for
NBC News Richard angles new book on the
Middle East was reviewed by Kevin
Canfield for the Kansas City Star he
writes that at heart the book is a
nerve-wracking autobiography by a
journalist on the front lines covering
Wars and terrorism in Lebanon Israel
Gaza Iraq and Syria on another level
it's an informative portrait of a
troubled region one that has been unduly
influenced by charlatans and madmen and
poorly served by two consecutive
American presidents in this Sunday's New
York Times Book Review david ershon skee
a history professor at new york
university reviewed adam Cohen's new
book about state-sponsored sterilization
in the United States and the
precedent-setting Supreme Court case
buck V Bell professor of schinsky notes
that at its height from the late 1920s
through the 1950s forced sterilization
in the United States would claim tens of
thousands of victims with California and
a host of southern states leading the
way the procedures were performed so
often on poor white Southerners Cohen
writes that they acquired a nickname
Mississippi appendectomies and the
George W Bush Institute recently
released a book which profiles the lives
of several women in Afghanistan who are
fighting for civil rights
Kirkus Reviews says that this work
continually sounds the themes of
confidence and self improvement which
can only be achieved when women raised
their voices and overcome a societal and
forced [ __ ]